From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, has spent a few years reporting on the history of one school-- it's a public school in a big city-- and at the beginning, we kind of thought the story was about segregation and inequality in public schools. But the more she spoke to people and researched what had happened at this one school, the more she realized it was actually about the inordinate amount of power that white parents had at this one school. And she found so many stories there that we realized we couldn't fit it all into one episode of our program and that we would need to release it as its own little mini-series podcast.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们的制作人之一查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）花了几年时间报道了一所学校的历史——这是一所位于大城市的公立学校。起初，我们以为这个故事是关于公立学校的种族隔离和不平等问题的。但随着她与更多人交流并深入研究这所学校发生的事情，她意识到，故事的核心其实是白人家长在这所学校所拥有的过大权力。她在那儿发现了太多故事，以至于我们意识到无法将它们全部塞进一期节目中，于是我们需要把它制作成一个独立的迷你播客系列。
So last week, a little three-minute trailer was released. The name of the show is Nice White Parents. And even before the first episodes appeared, it became this war-- thousands of ratings and comments online at Apple Podcasts, people saying it's divisive, that it's racist to talk about white parents, giving the show one-star reviews, other people giving it five-star reviews to cancel out the one-star reviews.
上周，一段三分钟的预告片发布了，节目名字叫《不错的白人家长》（Nice White Parents）。在第一集播出之前，它就已经引发了一场“战争”——苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上有成千上万的评分和评论，人们说这档节目具有分裂性，谈论白人家长是种族主义的表现，纷纷给出差评；而另一部分人则给出五星好评以抵消差评。
Remember, nobody had heard the show yet. The comments were about some imagined thing that people thought that the show would be, rather than the actual story that Chana tells, which is kind of funny. I think it also speaks to how the entire subject freaks people out so much. White parent-- how rarely that is explicitly named as the subject of reporting.
要知道，当时还没人听过这档节目。这些评论针对的是人们心中想象的节目内容，而非查娜讲述的真实故事，这挺有意思。这也说明了整个议题让人感到多么不安。“白人家长”——这个群体作为报道的对象，在公开场合被明确提及的次数实在太少了。
There is so much reporting on people of color as people of color, and so little reporting on white people as white people, even when they're at the heart of a story, as they are with this one. And when you listen to what Chana found, you feel how rare it is. I personally found it illuminating. You can listen and judge for yourself.
关于有色人种作为“有色人种”的报道铺天盖地，而关于白人作为“白人”的报道却少之又少，即使他们就像在这个故事里一样，是事件的核心。当你听完查娜的调查后，你会感觉到这种报道是多么稀缺。我个人觉得深受启发。你可以听一听，然后自己评判。
Today, we're presenting right here one of the stories that Chana tells in her series about one of the big turning points in the school's recent history. Before we start, I want to note everything you're going to hear this hour was recorded before coronavirus arrived, so it is a world where people get together in person with no masks or anything. Don't be shocked. All right, here's Chana.
今天，我们就在这里呈现查娜系列报道中的一个故事，讲述的是这所学校近期历史的一个重大转折点。开始之前，我想说明一下，本小时你听到的所有内容都是在新冠疫情到来之前录制的，所以那是一个人们可以不戴口罩、面对面聚在一起的世界。请不要感到惊讶。好了，有请查娜。
I started reporting this story at the very same moment as I was trying to figure out my own relationship to the subject of this story-- white parents in New York City public schools. I was about to be one of them. When my kid was old enough, I started learning about my options. I had many. There was our zoned public school in Brooklyn, or I could apply to a handful of specialty programs, a gifted program, or a magnet school, or a language program. So I started to look around.
我开始报道这个故事的时候，正好也在梳理自己与这个故事主题——纽约市公立学校里的白人家长——之间的关系。我当时也即将成为其中一员。当我的孩子到了入学年龄，我开始了解自己的选择。我有很多选择：布鲁克林的一所学区公立学校，或者申请一些特色项目、天才班、磁校（Magnet School）或语言项目。于是我开始四处考察。
This was five years ago now, but I vividly remember these tours. I'd show up in the lobby of the school at the time listed on the website, look around, and notice that all or almost all of the other parents who had shown up for the 11:00 AM, middle of the workday, early in the shopping season school tour were other white parents. As a group, we'd walk the halls, following a school administrator, almost always a man or woman of color, through a school full of Black and brown kids. We'd peer into classroom windows, watch the kids sit in a circle on the rug, ask questions about the lunch menu, homework policy, discipline. Some of us would take notes.
那是五年前的事了，但我对那些参观记忆犹新。我会按照网站上列出的时间出现在学校大厅，环顾四周，发现所有或几乎所有参加早上11点（工作日中间、招生季早期）参观的家长，都是白人家长。我们一行人跟随学校的一位管理人员（通常是有色人种男女）穿过走廊，走廊里满是黑人和棕色人种的孩子。我们从教室窗户往里看，看着孩子们在地毯上围成一圈，询问关于午餐菜单、家庭作业政策、纪律管理的问题。我们中的一些人会做笔记。
And the administrators would sell. The whole thing was essentially a pitch. We offer STEM. We have a partnership with Lincoln Center. We have a dance studio. They were pleading with us to please take part in this public school.
校方人员则极力推销。整个参观本质上就是一场推介会。“我们提供STEM课程，我们与林肯中心有合作，我们有舞蹈室。”他们恳求我们要入读这所公立学校。
I don't think I've ever felt my own consumer power more viscerally than I did shopping for a public school as a white parent. We were entering schools that people like us had ignored for decades. They were not our places, but we were being invited to make them ours.
作为一名白人家长，在为孩子挑选公立学校时，我从未如此真切地感受到自己的“消费者权力”。我们进入的是那些像我们这样的人已经忽视了几十年的学校。它们本不是我们的地盘，但现在我们被邀请去把它们变成我们的地盘。
The whole thing was made so much more awkward by the fact that nobody on those tours ever acknowledged the obvious racial difference, that roughly 100% of the parents in this group did not match, say, 90% of the kids in this building. I remember one time being guided into a classroom and being told that this was the class for gifted kids and noticing, oh, here's where all the white kids are. Everyone on our tour saw this, all of us parents, but nobody said anything, including me.
整个过程最尴尬的一点是，参观中没有任何人提及显而易见的种族差异——这个家长群体中几乎100%的人，与这栋楼里90%的孩子完全不匹配。我记得有一次被带进一间教室，被告知这是“天才班”，我立刻注意到：哦，原来白人孩子都在这里。我们参观团的所有人都看到了这一点，但没有人说话，包括我。
We walked out into the hallway. A mom raised her hand and said, I do have one question I've been meaning to ask. And the group got quiet. I was thinking, OK here it comes. But then she said, do the kids here play outside every day?
我们走进走廊，一位妈妈举手说：“我有一个一直想问的问题。”大家安静了下来。我想：“好吧，重点来了。”但她说：“这里的孩子每天都在外面玩吗？”
I knew the schools were segregated. I shouldn't have been surprised. By the time I was touring schools as a parent, I'd spent a fair amount of time in schools as a reporter. I'd done stories on the stark inequality in public education, and I'd looked at some of the many programs and reforms we've tried to fix our schools-- so many ideas. We've tried standardized tests and charter schools. We've tried smaller classes, longer school days, stricter discipline, looser discipline, tracking, differentiation. We've decided the problem is teachers. The problem is parents.
我知道学校存在种族隔离。我不该感到惊讶。在我以家长的身份参观学校之前，我已经以记者的身份在学校里花了不少时间。我报道过公立教育中严峻的不平等问题，也研究过我们试图修复学校的许多项目和改革方案——点子多得数不清。我们尝试过标准化测试、特许学校。我们试过小班教学、延长上学时间、严苛纪律、宽松纪律、分层教学、差异化教学。我们最后得出结论：问题出在老师身上，或者是出在家长身上。
What is true about almost all of these reforms is that when we look for what's broken, for how our schools are failing, we focus on who they're failing-- poor kids, Black kids, and brown kids. We ask, why aren't they performing better? Why aren't they achieving more?
关于几乎所有这些改革，真相在于：当我们寻找哪里出了问题，寻找学校为何失败时，我们的焦点总是放在受害者身上——那些贫困的孩子、黑人孩子和棕色人种孩子。我们问：“为什么他们表现不够好？为什么他们没能取得更多成就？”
Those are not the right questions. There is a powerful force that is shaping our public schools, arguably the most powerful force. It's there even when we pretend not to notice it, like on that school tour. If you want to understand why our schools aren't better, that's where you have to look. You have to look at white parents. That's what this story is about.
这些问题问错了。有一种强大的力量正在塑造我们的公立学校，甚至可以说是最强大的力量。即使当我们假装没看见它时，它也就在那里，就像在那次参观中一样。如果你想明白为什么我们的学校不够好，你必须看向那里。你必须看向白人家长。这就是这个故事的主题。
I'm going to take you inside a public school building, an utterly ordinary, squat, three-story New York City public school building not too far from where I live. This isn't one of the schools I toured, and my own kids don't go here. They're too little. This is a middle and high school called the School for International Studies, SIS. The story of this school and its relationship with white parents down the block span 60 years, but the part I want to tell you begins at SIS in the spring of 2015, right before everything at the school changed.
我将带你进入一所公立学校大楼，一所再普通不过的、矮墩墩的三层纽约市公立学校，离我不远。这不是我参观过的那几所学校，我的孩子也不在这里上学，他们还太小。这是一所叫“国际研究学校”（School for International Studies，简称SIS）的中学和高中。这所学校与其街区白人家长的关系跨越了60年，但我想要讲述的部分始于2015年春天，就在学校一切发生改变之前。
In 2015, the students at SIS were Black, Latino, and Middle Eastern kids, mostly from working class and poor families. That year, like the year before and the year before that, the school was shrinking. The principal, Jillian Juman, was worried.
2015年，SIS的学生大多是黑人、拉丁裔和中东裔孩子，多来自工薪阶层和贫困家庭。那一年，像往年一样，学校规模正在缩减。校长吉莉安·朱曼（Jillian Juman）很担心。
Yeah, so the last two years, we had 30 students in our sixth grade class. We really have room for 100. So numbers, I think, are hard.
“是的，过去两年，我们的六年级只有30名学生。我们其实有容纳100人的空间。所以我觉得，这些数字很棘手。”
Ms. Juman started to reach out to families from the neighborhood, inviting them to please come take a look. Parents started showing up for tours of SIS, mostly groups of white parents. Ms. Juman was thrilled and relieved. She walked parents through the building, saying, stop me anytime. If anyone has any questions, really anything, I want you to feel comfortable.
朱曼校长开始联络社区家庭，邀请他们来看看。家长们开始出现参观SIS，大多数是白人家长。朱曼校长既兴奋又如释重负。她带领家长参观大楼，说：“随时打断我。如果有人有任何问题，真的，任何问题，我希望你们感到舒适。”
And Ms. Juman says they did have questions, mostly about the poor test scores. That was fair. Ms. Juman expected those questions. She did not expect the other set of questions she got a lot from parents.
朱曼校长说，他们确实有问题，大多是关于糟糕的考试成绩。这很公平，她也预料到了这些问题。但她没预料到家长们提出的另一系列问题。
Is there weapons? Is there-- are you scanning? Are you a scanning school? Because kids are dangerous, and they have weapons.
“这里有武器吗？你们进行安检吗？你们是需要安检的学校吗？因为孩子们很危险，他们有武器。”
Scanning, like metal detectors?
“安检，是指金属探测器吗？”
Right. I heard there's fights and those kinds of things. I don't know what school you're talking about. I have never heard of that incident ever happening ever. So the fears of what this building is and what this building has represented has kind of transcended itself. There's a different story of international studies outside this building.
“对。我听说这里有打架之类的事件。我不知道你们在说哪所学校。我从未听说过这类事件发生过。所以，对于这栋大楼是什么、代表什么的恐惧，已经超越了事实本身。在这栋大楼之外，有着关于国际研究学校完全不同的说法。”
How much of that do you think is racism?
“你觉得这其中有多少是种族主义？”
I think our entire society is fearful of the unknown.
“我觉得我们整个社会都对未知感到恐惧。”
Excellent principal answer. Principal Juman is Black, by the way. She needed these parents. Schools get money per student. A shrinking school means a shrinking budget. Ms. Juman was worried, if this continued, the middle school could be in danger of being shut down by the city.
非常高明的校长回答。顺便提一下，朱曼校长是黑人。她需要这些家长。学校是按人头获得拨款的。学校规模缩减意味着预算缩减。朱曼校长担心，如果这种情况持续下去，这所中学可能会面临被市政当局关闭的风险。
SIS is in Cobble Hill, Brooklyn-- leafy streets, brownstones. It's a wealthy, white neighborhood that's gotten wealthier and whiter in the last decade. But white families were not sending their kids to SIS.
SIS位于布鲁克林的科布尔山（Cobble Hill）——那里街道绿树成荫，布满褐砂石建筑。这是一个富裕的白人社区，在过去十年里变得更富裕、更白了。但白人家庭却不愿送孩子去SIS。
Ms. Juman told these parents, choose SIS. We're turning things around. We're in the process of bringing in a new, prestigious International Baccalaureate curriculum, renovating the library. Here's the new gorgeous yard. It's an excellent school. The parents seemed interested, but I believe that might have had just as much to do with what was happening outside of the school as what they were seeing inside the building.
朱曼校长告诉这些家长：“选择SIS吧。我们正在扭转局面。我们正在引入全新的、享有盛誉的国际文凭（IB）课程，翻修图书馆。这是新建的漂亮院子。这是一所优秀的学校。”家长们似乎很感兴趣，但我相信这与学校外发生的事情，和他们在学校内看到的东西同样重要。
Sure. So my name is Rob Hansen, and I'm a parent. So we were-- the middle school process is interesting.
“当然。我叫罗布·汉森（Rob Hansen），我也是一位家长。中学择校过程很有趣。”
Rob lives nearby SIS, but he had never heard of the school. In his district, Rob could choose from 11 middle schools. The majority of white families sent their kids to the same three schools. Rob's white. Those are the schools he'd heard of, and those were the schools he toured. But they were packed. There were too many wealthy white families in the district to continue cramming into just three schools.
罗布就住在SIS附近，但他从未听说过这所学校。在他的学区，罗布可以选择11所中学。大多数白人家庭把孩子送到同样的3所学校。罗布是白人。他只听说过那些学校，也只参观过那些学校。但它们都挤爆了。学区里有太多富有的白人家庭，无法继续挤进那三所学校里。
There's a couple of citywide ones where we went and we stood in line for like an hour, an hour and a half, and then joined in an auditorium full of parents, and then had them announce that they were accepting 15 students in the coming class.
“有几所全市招生的学校，我们去排队等了一个半小时，然后挤进一个坐满家长的礼堂，结果被告知他们下一届只录取15名学生。”
And they'd been running tours all day. Most cities have some amount of school choice like this, tours and options. New York City, though, is an amped-up version of what happens elsewhere-- the level of competition, the level of wealth, the diversity of people sorting into different schools. Everything is more intense.
他们整天都在进行参观活动。大多数城市都有类似的学校选择、参观和名额。但在纽约，这是其他地方情况的“加强版”——竞争程度、财富水平、人们分流到不同学校的多样性。一切都更加激烈。
Rob found this process frustrating. Although Rob is very even-tempered, even when he's frustrated-- he's Canadian-- when he gets especially hot, he starts calling things interesting. And this whole middle school thing was very interesting.
罗布对这个过程感到沮丧。虽然罗布性格非常温和，即便在沮丧时也是如此——他是加拿大人——但当他特别激动时，他开始用“有趣”这个词来形容事物。而整个中学择校过程非常“有趣”。
He asked other parents on school tours, what are we going to do? Someone said, have you guys heard of SIS, that building down the block? Rob hadn't. The others hadn't. They decided to all go check it out together.
他在学校参观活动中问其他家长：“我们该怎么办？”有人说：“你们听说过SIS吗？就街对面那栋楼？”罗布没听说过，其他人也没听说过。他们决定一起去看看。
I walked away, and lots of parents walked away from those tours thinking, wow, people are jamming up into some schools, and you're leaving 60 or 70 seats empty, empty all year long. You have 30 kids. You spread them out around-- and that's a big school. Then all of a sudden you're sort of like, wait a second. There's nobody here.
“我离开时，很多家长都在想：哇，人们挤破头想进某些学校，而这里却有60到70个空位整年闲置。你们只有30个孩子，分散在这么大一所学校里。然后突然间你会想：等一下，这儿没人。”
As Rob toured SIS, he had an idea. That night, he emailed Principal Juman, and he asked, would she be open to starting a dual-language French program at SIS? They had one at the elementary school Rob's kids went to, and everyone loved it. Sure, Principal Juman was open.
罗布在参观SIS时产生了一个想法。那天晚上，他给朱曼校长发了电子邮件，问她是否愿意在SIS开设双语法语课程。罗布孩子就读的小学就有这个项目，大家都非常喜欢。朱曼校长当然愿意。
So Rob started spreading the word. SIS is starting a dual-language French program. We should all go. Rob says there was interest, but a lot of people he talked to had this question-- wait, are other people going?
于是，罗布开始传播消息：“SIS要开设双语法语课程了。我们都该去。”罗布说当时大家很感兴趣，但和他交谈的很多人都有个问题——“等等，还有其他人要去吗？”
And then families have that kind of fear. Like, what if I'm-- you know, if I look around, nobody else came with me. And I came for something that's not here because nobody-- so it's a collective action problem.
“家庭会有那种恐惧。比如，如果我环顾四周，发现没别人跟我一起去。我冲着某些东西去，但如果去的人太少，项目就开不起来。这是一个‘集体行动难题’。”
Wait, why is it a collective-- why do you need a collective?
“等等，为什么这是一个集体行动问题？为什么你需要一个群体？”
I think overall there's a collective action issue. But if you're interested in this in part because of the French dual language part of it, if you're the only one to show up, there's no French teacher for one student. But there's a program if 15 come, if 20 come. But we all have to then take one step forward at exactly the same time. The vision requires people to come. And what if nobody comes?
“我觉得总体上存在一个集体行动问题。如果你因为法语双语项目而感兴趣，但如果你是唯一一个出现的人，那么就没有法语老师教一个学生。但如果来了15个、20个人，项目就成了。我们必须在同一时间齐步向前。愿景需要人们参与。可万一没人来呢？”
When it came time to choose middle schools, parents are supposed to rank their top choices. Right before they did, before everyone chose their schools, Rob sent a survey out to the families he'd been talking to, to try to ensure that a group of them would choose SIS together. It was a simple SurveyMonkey. If enough people said yes, they'd rank SIS as one of their top picks, and they would be able to act as a collective.
到了选择中学的时候，家长们需要对他们的首选学校进行排序。就在他们行动之前，在每个人选校之前，罗布向他交谈过的家庭发了一份调查问卷，试图确保他们中有一群人会一起选择SIS。那是一个简单的SurveyMonkey调查。如果足够多的人说“是”，他们就会把SIS列为首选之一，他们就能作为一个集体采取行动。
People said yes. The numbers were stunning. In 2014, there had been 30 sixth graders at SIS. In 2015, there would be 103. That 200% increase was almost entirely white kids.
大家回答了“是”。人数多得惊人。2014年，SIS只有30名六年级学生。而2015年，人数达到了103人。这200%的增长几乎全都是白人孩子。
Did you think about yourself as integrators? Did you think about--
“你当时把自己看作融合推动者吗？你想过……”
No. My pause was because I was trying to think if that had gone through my mind. And no. No, not integrators-- participants in a school that was going to hopefully be diverse. But yeah, that's not a framing or a way of thinking about it that would have occurred to me at the time.
“不。我刚才停顿是因为我在想这是否曾出现在我的脑海里。不，不是融合推动者——而是作为一所希望实现多元化的学校的参与者。但是的，当时那种框架或思考方式从未出现在我的脑海里。”
Nobody I talked to from SIS characterized what was happening there as integration, but here's why integration was on my mind. The New York City Department of Education was aware their schools were segregated. It was also aware that desegregation is the most effective way to close the gap in achievement between Black and white students. But it did not want to mandate racial integration through zoning or school placements. The city was trying to make integration happen through choice, hoping to lure white families into segregated schools.
我采访的SIS相关人员没有人将正在发生的事情定义为“融合”。但这就是我思考的问题：纽约市教育局意识到他们的学校存在隔离，也意识到废除种族隔离是缩小黑人和白人学生成绩差距最有效的方法。但他们不想通过划区或指定入学来强制进行种族融合。该市正试图通过“选择”来实现融合，希望将白人家庭吸引到种族隔离学校中。
The school tours I went on for my own kids, those sparkly programs and amenities, that was the new approach to integration. But can this work-- for white parents to opt in to integration, not because we have to or because it's the right thing to do, but because it's a selling point? Because we get a dance studio, and STEM, and a school that was hopefully diverse-- integration without talking about race.
我为自己孩子参观学校时看到的那些花哨的项目和设施，就是这种新的融合尝试。但这行得通吗？让白人家长选择融合，不是因为必须这样做或这在道德上正确，而是因为这成了一个卖点？因为我们能得到舞蹈室、STEM课程，以及一所理应多元化的学校——一种避而不谈种族的融合。
[KIDS CHATTERING]
[孩子们嘈杂声]
The kids at SIS, though, they did talk about race immediately. Fall 2015, the first few weeks of school, a senior named Kristen leaned over to her classmate Chris and mumbles, there are a lot of white kids in the school. And Chris says, oh, yeah, a teacher warned me about that over the summer.
不过，SIS的孩子们立刻就开始谈论种族了。2015年秋季，开学几周后，一位叫克里斯汀（Kristen）的高年级学生向同学克里斯（Chris）低声说：“学校里多了好多白人小孩。”克里斯回答：“哦，是啊，暑假里老师就警告过我了。”
He told me, like, oh, there's going to be a lot of white kids coming in, French white kids from upper economic statuses. So be prepared for that.
“他告诉我，哦，会有很多白人孩子进来，经济地位较高的法语白人孩子。所以做好准备。”
Kristen nods. Yeah, I guess we were prepared. And then she turns to me to say, I should have been ready for that. We saw the parents on the tours last year.
克里斯汀点了点头。“是啊，我想我们确实做好了准备。”然后她转向我说：“我本该对此有心理准备的。去年我们参观时就看到那些家长了。”
We would see them walk through the hall, but we never knew it was so serious that a whole group of Caucasians would come in, it would be so diverse. But it was such a big change. Not to be prejudiced or anything, but I noticed the big change. High schoolers are more Hispanics and Blacks, and with a few Caucasians. And the new group that came in were all Caucasians. They're trying to make it so diverse.
“我们曾看到他们穿过走廊，但从没想过会这么严重，一大群白人会进来，让学校变得如此多元。这真是巨大的变化。并不是我有什么偏见，但我注意到了这个巨大的变化。高中部之前大多是西班牙裔和黑人，只有少数白人。而新进来的那一组全都是白人。他们正试图让学校变得多元。”
Diverse, this was a word I heard over and over in the first few weeks of school-- diversity.
“多元”——这是开学几周里我不断听到的一个词，多元化。
I love diversity, so when I did see other white kids, I'm like, so?
“我喜欢多元化，所以当我看到其他白人孩子时，我的反应是：所以呢？”
Diversity seemed to have two different definitions. White families would talk about all the diversity at SIS, and they were talking about Black and Hispanic kids. When kids of color noted the diversity, they were referring to the new white kids. For a lot of kids of color, this looked a lot like something they'd already seen happen in their neighborhoods-- white families showing up in large numbers, taking over stores, familiar spots. There's a word for that. It's gentrification.
多元化似乎有两种不同的定义。白人家庭谈论SIS的多元化时，指的是那些黑人和拉美裔孩子。当有色人种孩子提到多元化时，指的是那些新来的白人孩子。对于很多有色人种孩子来说，这看起来就像他们在社区里已经见过的事情——白人家庭大举涌入，接管了商店、熟悉的地点。有个词形容这种现象：绅士化（Gentrification）。
But I noticed that no one was using that word about the school. What was happening here was diversity. That's how the adults talked about it. Diversity is a good thing, something you're supposed to be OK with. For the most part, the kids were.
但我注意到没人用这个词形容学校。这里发生的事被称为“多元化”。成年人就是这样谈论它的。多元化是好事，是你理应接受的事。大部分情况下，孩子们也是这么想的。
It was different for the parents. Some of them saw specific advantages to the diversity, like Kenya Blount, the co-vice president of the PTA at SIS. He was excited.
但家长们情况不同。有些人看到了这种多元化带来的具体优势，比如肯尼亚·布朗特（Kenya Blount），SIS家长教师协会（PTA）的副主席。他很兴奋。
Having the new parents coming in and the diversity that particularly comes from the new-- as I'll call it, the new neighborhood, the way that things are changing in the neighborhood, is that we have a gentleman who his profession is fundraising.
“新家长的到来，特别是这种来自我所称的‘新社区’的多元化——社区正在发生变化，我们有一位职业是筹款人的绅士。”
Rob Hansen, the dad who started the SurveyMonkey. Rob raises money for nonprofits and foundations for a living. Over the course of the year, I'll hear Rob Hansen referred to as Todd Hansen, Ted Manson, Mr. Handsome. Kenya was the only one who went with the gentlemen whose profession is fundraising. The most common was just the guy who gets the money.
罗布·汉森，那个发起SurveyMonkey调查的爸爸。罗布的职业是为非营利组织和基金会筹款。在这一年里，我听到有人把罗布·汉森称为托德·汉森（Todd Hansen）、特德·曼森（Ted Manson）、“帅哥先生”。肯尼亚是唯一一个称他为“职业是筹款人的绅士”的人。最常见的称呼只是“那个搞到钱的家伙”。
Rob told the PTA he was eager to raise money for the school. To Kenya, this meant more resources at his own kids' school. His boys and all the kids could benefit.
罗布告诉PTA，他渴望为学校筹款。对肯尼亚来说，这意味着他自己孩子所在的学校有了更多资源。他的儿子们和所有孩子都能受益。
He has brought on the challenge and taken it upon himself to raise $50,000.
“他接受了挑战，主动承担起筹集5万美元的任务。”
5-0?
“5-0？”
5, 0, with three zeros after that-- yes, $50,000, which, again, goes back to the whole, I'll say, diversity thing and new people who are thinking outside the box. As our PTA, I don't think that we were thinking that big.
“5，0，后面三个零——是的，5万美元。这又回到了我说的关于‘多元化’的事情，以及那些跳出固有思维的人。作为PTA，我觉得我们之前没想过那么大的规模。”
They were definitely not thinking that big, because the PTA was run by Imee Hernandez and her co-president, Susan Moesker. Imee is not a gentleman who fundraises. She's a social worker. The first time I met Imee, she was wearing a T-shirt that said, "I'm not spoiled. My husband just loves me."
他们确实没想过那么大，因为PTA是由艾米·埃尔南德斯（Imee Hernandez）和她的联席主席苏珊·莫斯克（Susan Moesker）运营的。艾米不是那种“职业是筹款的绅士”。她是一名社工。我第一次见到艾米时，她穿着一件印有“我没被宠坏，我丈夫只是很爱我”字样的T恤。
She's Puerto Rican, grew up in Brooklyn. Her husband, Maurice, is Puerto Rican and Black, and really does adore her. He grew up in Brooklyn too. They have one daughter, one pit bull, one Persian cat, and one school.
她是波多黎各人，在布鲁克林长大。她的丈夫莫里斯（Maurice）是波多黎各和黑人混血，真的非常宠她。他也是在布鲁克林长大的。他们有一个女儿、一只比特犬、一只波斯猫，还有一所学校。
I make it my business to stick myself in her school. [LAUGHS]
“我把参与学校事务当作自己的事。”[笑]
For Imee, the new diversity, it gave her pause.
对艾米来说，这种新的多元化让她有些犹豫。
Like when I saw in September the population that came in, I was like, oh, that's a little frightening. [LAUGHS]
“就像9月份我看到进来的那些人，我当时想：哦，那有点吓人。”[笑]
Describe it for people who are on the radio and don't know what you saw.
“给电台听众描述一下你当时看到的情况吧。”
I saw a lot of white people with very high socioeconomic backgrounds. You know, they have money. And that's great, but money tends to scare people. And I'm one of the people it scares. [LAUGHS] I'm one of the people it scares because it twists everything around. And I don't like that. I don't like that.
“我看到了很多社会经济背景极高的人。你知道，他们有钱。这很好，但金钱往往会吓到人。我就是那种被吓到的人。[笑] 我被吓到是因为这把一切都搅乱了。我不喜欢那样。我不喜欢那样。”
I'd rather have a dinner where people of different cultures bring their food and we share together than have somebody else cater it. That's how I feel you build community. I'm a social worker. That's my background. And that's what I believe in.
“我更喜欢举办一场晚餐，不同文化背景的人带着自己的食物分享，而不是找人来承办。我认为这才叫建立社区。我是一名社工，那是我的背景。那是我所信仰的。”
Imee was in her second year at the school. The year before, she put on community events, teacher appreciation, a spring carnival with face painting and hot dogs. There is money here and there, but Imee's vision for the PTA wasn't really about fundraising. The new parents, though, they wanted to be active in their new school, and they were accustomed to supporting their kids' schools by fundraising. The two approaches came face to face at a PTA meeting in October.
艾米已经在学校待了第二年。前一年，她组织社区活动、老师感谢日、带有涂脸和热狗的春季嘉年华。钱有时多有时少，但艾米对PTA的愿景并不是筹款。然而，新家长们习惯于通过筹款来支持孩子所在的学校，他们也想在自己的新学校积极参与。在十月份的一次PTA会议上，这两种方法发生了碰撞。
Three more minutes--
“还有三分钟——”
All right, all right.
“好吧，好吧。”
--and then it's up to every--
“——然后大家就得……”
Oh, you're stressed.
“哦，你压力很大。”
Yes, I'm very-- because y'all got your-- you know, you got to go home. [LAUGHS] You got to go home.
“是的，我很——因为你们得……你们得回家了。[笑] 你们得回家了。”
There are about a dozen grown-ups sitting on small, plastic chairs around a classroom table-- the PTA executive board. Principal Juman is here too. Imee's leading, and the principal jumps in. She says she wants a minute to share how much the new fundraising committee had raised so far. Imee looks confused. Principal Juman goes on to say the new fundraising committee has had a lot of success.
大约有十几名成年人坐在教室桌子周围的小塑料椅上——这是PTA执行委员会。朱曼校长也在场。艾米在主持，校长插了进来。她说想花一分钟分享一下新的筹款委员会到目前为止筹集了多少资金。艾米看起来很困惑。朱曼校长接着说，新的筹款委员会取得了很大成功。
But total, they have raised, according to Rob, about $18,000. And then we just had a donation from a family a couple weeks ago who wanted to be anonymous, that they're going to give either $5,000 to $10,000 in December. So this is big money.
“总共，据罗布说，他们筹集了大约1.8万美元。然后几周前，一个家庭匿名捐款，他们要在12月捐5千到1万美元。所以这笔钱数额巨大。”
People seem unclear what to do with their faces. This is good news, right? But also, wait? What's the fundraising committee? Imee turns to her husband, Maurice, a retired cop. Maurice is also the treasurer of the PTA, because when he retired, his wife told him he couldn't just sit around at home.
人们似乎不知道该摆出什么表情。这是好消息，对吧？但等一下？筹款委员会是什么？艾米转向她的丈夫莫里斯，一位退休警察。莫里斯也是PTA的财务主管，因为他退休时，妻子告诉他不能只在家里闲着。
Maurice shrugs at Imee, doesn't seem to know anything about this new money. Imee turns back to Principal Juman. So can we use that money?
莫里斯对着艾米耸了耸肩，似乎对这笔新资金一无所知。艾米转向朱曼校长。“那么我们可以动用那笔钱吗？”
That was the question, if the PTA can have access to this money. Because I know already--
这是关键问题，即PTA是否能动用这些钱。
But what is the PTA? So that's also the question that keeps going around. So this $18,000 Rob has raised under the umbrella of PTA.
“但什么是PTA？这也是大家一直在问的问题。所以罗布在PTA名义下筹集的这1.8万美元……”
That's Principal Juman.
那是朱曼校长在说话。
OK.
“好的。”
I think.
“我想。”
But who's-- who's got it, and where's it-- this PTA member don't know nothing about it, so, you know.
“但谁——谁掌握着这笔钱，它在哪儿呢？PTA成员对此一无所知，所以你知道的……”
How can that be accessed for Mr. Negron?
“内格隆先生（Mr. Negron）如何申请动用这笔资金呢？”
Maurice asks, how can that money be accessed for Mr. Negron, who wants new gym uniforms, or Mr. Lowe to get his microscopes? Imee nods.
莫里斯问，内格隆先生需要新的体育制服，或者洛先生（Mr. Lowe）需要显微镜。艾米点了点头。
I mean, God bless Rob, and more power to him--
“我的意思是，上帝保佑罗布，这对他来说是有能力的表现——”
Yeah.
“是的。”
--but he's not an official member. So I think that's what makes it confusing, at least for me. He is a PTA member because he's a parent, but he's not part of the executive board. So I think that's what makes it--
“——但他不是官方成员。所以我觉得这正是让人困惑的地方，至少对我来说是这样。他是PTA成员，因为他是家长，但他不是执行委员会的一部分。所以我想这让事情……”
That's probably true.
“这可能是真的。”
Yeah, it makes it tricky. I mean, and again, I'm not-- he can bring more money, that's great, but, you know.
“是的，这让事情变得棘手。我的意思是，同样，我不是——他能带来更多钱那很好，但你知道……”
Principal Juman nods, repeats that she wishes Rob had been able to make it. She was hoping everyone could be here and get on the same page about money. But Rob is chaperoning a sixth grade overnight trip. They're late getting back.
朱曼校长点了点头，重复说她希望罗布能参加会议。她希望大家能聚在一起，对资金达成共识。但罗布正在带队六年级隔夜旅行，回来晚了。
One mom, a white woman who came in with the new group of sixth graders, says, look, I know Rob. He means well.
一位随新六年级群体加入的白人妈妈说：“看，我认识罗布。他是好心。”
I think Rob-- he's a professional fundraiser.
“我觉得罗布——他是一位专业筹款人。”
Yes, he's great.
“是的，他很棒。”
And therefore he took it as his initiative--
“所以他以此为契机——”
They need money.
“他们需要钱。”
--to do the fundraising.
“——来进行筹款。”
Yeah.
“是啊。”
And I think that's great, but I don't-- he should communicate with the PTA. And my impression is I don't think he's meaning to offend anybody.
“我觉得那很好，但我认为他不应该——他应该和PTA沟通。我的印象是，我觉得他无意冒犯任何人。”
No, no, no.
“不，不，不。”
I think he's sort of so laser focused that he's not thinking about, well, maybe you might want to let somebody know what he's doing.
“我觉得他只是过于专注，以至于没考虑到，嗯，也许你可能想让别人知道他在做什么。”
And he's been amazing. He really has. Yeah, yeah.
“而且他太令人惊奇了。他真的很好。”
That's Principal Juman. At this point, everyone seems to feel a little weird about how long they've spent talking about a fellow parent who is not present. And anyway, it's money for the school. We're all for that. We just need better communication. Imee says, yeah, it's just usually money raised by parents goes through the PTA so we can all talk about where to spend it.
那是朱曼校长在说话。此时，大家似乎都觉得讨论一位不在场的家长花了这么长时间有点奇怪。不管怎样，这是给学校的钱。我们都支持。我们只需要更好的沟通。艾米说，是啊，通常家长筹集的钱会经过PTA，这样大家可以共同讨论如何花费。
And then we have to decide who has the say. Because if it's a collective PTA--
“然后我们必须决定谁有话语权。因为如果这是一个集体的PTA……”
Hey.
“嘿。”
There's Rob.
“是罗布。”
There he is.
“他来了。”
Sorry I'm late.
“抱歉我来晚了。”
Then it would be--
“那么这将是……”
Yay.
“耶。”
I can't believe you made it out there every--
“真不敢相信你……”
Rob walks into the room. He just got back from the sixth grade trip. He sits down, and they all start to talk. We need to sort out some questions about money. Then a mom from the fundraising committee says she's worried about me recording and asked me to stop, so I do.
罗布走进了房间。他刚从六年级旅行回来。他坐下来，他们开始谈话。我们需要解决一些关于钱的问题。这时，一位筹款委员会的妈妈说她担心我在录音，要求我停止，于是我照做了。
Going on.
“继续。”
Being requested, but we don't know--
“虽然被要求了，但我们不知道……”
They let me stay though. I take notes. Rob apologizes and then explains.
但他们让我留下了。我记了笔记。罗布道歉并做出了解释。
A group of them have been meeting to raise money for the school. The new dual-language French program is expensive, and they promised the principal they'd help raise money to cover it. They were just eager to help, Rob says, so they formed a committee. He's really sorry. He should have communicated and coordinated better with the PTA.
他们中有一群人聚在一起为学校筹款。新的法语双语课程很贵，他们向校长承诺会帮助筹款覆盖费用。罗布说，他们只是渴望帮忙，所以成立了一个委员会。他真的很抱歉。他本应该更好地与PTA沟通和协调。
But good news is it's going great. Someone has a contact with the French embassy, a guy at the cultural services arm in New York. And he says he wants to help cover the costs of new French teachers and books. They've already kicked in around $10,000.
但好消息是进展顺利。有人联系了法国大使馆，是纽约文化服务部门的一位人士。他说他愿意帮助覆盖新法语教师和教材的费用。他们已经出资约1万美元了。
At this point in my notes I wrote, "Lots of looks, big money." Rob says, the embassy suggested we do a fundraiser, an event. They can help. Here I wrote, "Looks-- confused, mad?" Nobody really talking.
此时我在笔记中写道：“神情各异，大笔金额。”罗布说，大使馆建议他们举办一场筹款活动。他们可以提供帮助。这里我写道：“神情——困惑、愤怒？”没人真正说话。
Imee says, this fundraiser will be at the school though, right, and free for everyone? Rob says yes. Good, good. She asks one more time-- free? I just want to make sure everyone can go. Lots of nods. Rob says totally. This is a community event for our community.
艾米说，这场筹款活动在学校举办，对吧，而且对每个人免费？罗布说是的。好，好。她又问了一次——免费？“我只是想确保每个人都能参加。”很多人点头。罗布说绝对免费。这是一场为我们社区举办的社区活动。
After about 20 minutes, Imee says, we're out of time, guys. I can't tell if this is out of a professional commitment Imee has to stick to the schedule or a personal commitment to getting out of that room.
大约20分钟后，艾米说：“时间到了，各位。”我无法判断这是出于艾米必须遵守日程的职业素养，还是出于想要离开那个房间的个人意愿。
Before I came to SIS, I never thought much about the role of PTAs ever. At SIS early on, I had this feeling of, oh, a PTA is actually critical to the success of an integrated school. A PTA has a very simple, democratic structure. Every parent has an equal vote-- smart. It's like a built-in system to equalize power, to help them make a budget together, make decisions, set priorities collectively-- or not.
在来到SIS之前，我从未过多思考过PTA的作用。在SIS早期，我有一种感觉：哦，PTA其实对一所融合学校的成功至关重要。PTA有一个非常简单、民主的结构。每个家长有一票相等的投票权——很聪明。这就像一个内置的均衡权力系统，帮助他们共同制定预算、做出决定、设定集体优先事项——或者反之。
So we're lucky enough we have Rob here, who has really taken over fundraising and tried to bring it to the next level here in our school.
“我们很幸运有罗布在这里，他真的接手了筹款工作，并试图将其提升到一个新的水平。”
It's another PTA meeting, and the whole collective thing is not really happening. It seems like the new parents are still raising money separate from the PTA, and the communication problems do not seem to be resolved. And some of the new parents have an idea. They propose a formal separation, the PTA and the people doing fundraising. Rob says this way there'll be two organizations collecting money for SIS.
又是一次PTA会议，所谓“集体”的事并没有发生。看起来新家长们仍然在PTA之外单独筹款，沟通问题似乎并未解决。一些新家长有了一个主意。他们提议正式分开：PTA和负责筹款的人。罗布说这样会有两个组织为SIS筹集资金。
--is there will be two sorts of ways dollars are raised. One would be a community raise-- big sales, direct gifts.
“……会有两种筹集资金的方式。一种是社区筹集——大型义卖、直接捐赠。”
That would be the PTA side, the community funds. Then there would be a separate organization that would go after grants and big donors. Up until this point, there seemed to be tension bubbling under the surface between the new parents and the old parents, but it wasn't really until this moment that the unsaid started to get said, mostly by Imee's husband, Maurice.
那是PTA方面，社区基金。然后会有一个独立的组织去争取补助金和大捐赠者。直到这一点，新家长和老家长之间似乎一直潜伏着紧张情绪，但直到这一刻，未被言明的东西开始被说出来，主要是通过艾米的丈夫莫里斯。
I think a lot of us feel there's two different groups. There's the fundraising group and a PTA, which is-- you know, that's what it looks like. You guys have this goal of making $50,000, and it's going to the French program. Now, as you said, what about the rest of the school? Where's all this money going? We have no answer. We don't know.
“我觉得我们很多人都觉得有两个不同的群体。一个是筹款小组，一个是PTA，这看起来就是这样。你们有筹集5万美元的目标，并且全投向了法语项目。现在，正如你所说，学校的其他部分呢？这些钱到底都去哪儿了？我们没有答案。我们不知道。”
It's very easy to feel steamrolled.
“很容易感到被碾压。”
That's Maureen, a white mom who's new. There are lots of nods. Maurice is asking, is this new money you're talking about, is it just for the new French dual-language program, which is another way of asking, is this money just for your kids, or is it for everybody? Rob says emphatically, it's for everybody. Maurice says, really?
那是莫琳（Maureen），一位新加入的白人妈妈。大家纷纷点头。莫里斯问道，这是你说的这笔新资金，仅仅是为了那个新的法语双语项目吗？这其实是问：这笔钱是只为了你们的孩子，还是为了大家？罗布强调说：“是为了大家。”莫里斯说：“真的吗？”
I mean, that's being naive. We think, OK, they're going to donate all this money through the French embassy. OK, we're going to buy new chalkboards. That's being naive. Now you're saying the $50,000 is going to be for the PTA community to decide where it's going to go. So, I mean, I hear what you're saying, which sounds great. But again, maybe I'm still thinking about last meeting, when Jillian said, OK, well, we're only going to get a percentage of that. So we still don't have an answer.
“我的意思是，那太天真了。我们想，好的，他们会通过法国大使馆捐赠所有这些钱。好的，我们要买新的黑板。那太天真了。现在你说这5万美元将由PTA社区决定去向。所以，我的意思是，我听到了你在说什么，这听起来很好。但同样，也许我还停留在上次会议上，当时吉莉安说，好吧，我们要得到的只是其中的一个百分比。所以我们仍然没有答案。”
Later, talking to Rob, I learned that the new separate fundraising arm he's talking about is actually a foundation. They want to create a school-based foundation at SIS. The plan is to call it the Brooklyn World Project. I asked Rob, why do you need another way to raise money?
后来与罗布交谈，我了解到他所说的那个独立的筹款分支其实是一个基金会。他们想在SIS建立一个校本基金会。计划称其为“布鲁克林世界项目”（Brooklyn World Project）。我问罗布，为什么需要另一种筹款方式？
There's a PTA. Most people have heard of a school PTA. Why do you need a separate organization that's not the PTA?
“这里有PTA。大多数人都听说过学校PTA。为什么你需要一个独立于PTA之外的组织？”
Yeah. So probably the easiest way to explain it is to not think about it from the school side, but to think about it from the potential donor side. So basic idea that we're following is that the-- let's say the International says, we want to do extend a day, and we want to do theater. And so we go and we find a donor who loves theater, and loves the French language, and loves the idea that kids who've never spoken French and had no exposure get the chance to go and compete, actually, against some of the most established schools in the city.
“是的。最简单的解释方法是不从学校角度考虑，而是从潜在捐赠者角度考虑。我们遵循的基本理念是：假设国际学校说，我们想延长上学时间，我们想做戏剧。于是我们去找一个热爱戏剧、热爱法语、热爱让从未说法语、从未接触过法语的孩子们有机会去参加比赛，甚至去挑战城里一些最顶尖学校的捐赠者。”
And a donor just loves that. They're like, I love it. I love giving that kind of opportunity to kids. I'm going to cover all of that because I think it's that important.
“捐赠者会爱上它。他们说：我喜欢。我喜欢给孩子们提供那样的机会。我会覆盖所有这些费用，因为我认为它很重要。”
If that money goes to the PTA, you could have a situation where the PTA says or members of the PTA say, I don't know that we really like the theater program. I'm not sure. I think that we should be using those dollars to do X, or Y, or Z. Now, normally you'd be able to say, well, donor intent is what it is. You should probably use it towards what it was intended for.
“如果这笔钱流向PTA，可能会出现PTA说，或者PTA成员说：我不知道我们是否真的喜欢这个戏剧项目。我不确定。我认为我们应该把这笔钱用到X、Y或Z项目上。通常情况下，你会说，捐赠意愿就是捐赠意愿。你应该照它本来的意图去使用它。”
You mean normally, in another fundraising context?
“你是说通常在其他筹款背景下吗？”
Yeah, meaning in nonprofits. So there's a basic kind of morality of a nonprofit to say, if a donor gives it to you to do something, you should try to do that. Donor intent is an important part of it. It's sort of a trust that's established.
“是的，意味着在非营利组织中。所以非营利组织有一个基本的道德准则，即：如果捐赠者给你这笔钱做某事，你应该尝试那样去做。捐赠意愿是其中重要的部分。这是一种建立的信任。”
Rob says because the PTA is a democracy, it makes things complicated. The very thing I saw as a strength of a PTA-- one parent, one vote-- to Rob, that's a problem for fundraising. Parents come and go, and change their minds about what's important. A private donor wants stability, and Rob is trying to raise money for the kind of programming that was available at his son's wealthy elementary school.
罗布说，因为PTA是一个民主机构，这让事情变得复杂。我曾将其视为PTA优势的东西——家长一人一票——在罗布看来，这对于筹款是个问题。家长来来去去，对什么是重要的看法也不断改变。私人捐赠者想要稳定性，而罗布正试图为那种在他儿子所在富裕小学提供的项目进行筹款。
At that school, Rob was co-president of the PTA. In the previous year, his PTA pulled in close to $800,000, $800,000, money that paid for after-school programming, and ballroom dancing, chess, art, music, a garden-- $800,000 for a school that is 75% white and serves a tiny fraction of the poor kids in the district. There aren't enough wealthy parents at SIS to raise that kind of money. That year, Rob helped raise $800,000, the SIS PTA raised $2,000. So Rob was trying to be creative. A foundation was a way for his new school to catch up.
在那所学校，罗布曾是PTA联席主席。前一年，他的PTA筹集了近80万美元。这些钱支付了课后项目、交谊舞、国际象棋、艺术、音乐、花园——为一所75%是白人、服务学区内极少数贫困学生的学校筹集了80万美元。SIS没有足够的富有家长筹集到那种数额的钱。那一年，罗布帮助筹集了80万美元，SIS的PTA只筹集了2000美元。所以罗布正试图发挥创意。基金会是他新学校迎头赶上的方式。
The school leadership, the principal was behind the idea. Ms. Juman told me she saw the foundation as a path to equity and access. More resources meant they'd be able to provide all kids with opportunities, like, say, a school trip to France. But the parent leadership, they found it annoying.
学校领导、校长都支持这个想法。朱曼校长告诉我，她将基金会视为通向公平和准入的途径。更多资源意味着他们能为所有孩子提供机会，比如学校去法国的旅行。但家长领导层觉得这很烦人。
Imee knew the new parents were trying to help the school, but she already liked the school. She felt like she was being saved against her will. Plus, they're new, she said. Shouldn't we be the ones helping them?
艾米知道新家长们是在试图帮助学校，但她已经喜欢上了这所学校。她感觉自己像是被强行“被拯救”了。而且，“他们是新来的，”她说，“难道不应该是我们帮助他们吗？”
She was fine with them bringing in ideas, but she didn't understand why they hadn't brought them to her first. They hadn't thought to consult her. She said to me multiple times, why are they coming up with all these private plans and meeting in secret committees?
她不介意他们带来想法，但她不明白为什么他们没有第一时间带给她。他们没想到要咨询她。她多次对我说：“为什么他们想出这些私人计划，还在秘密委员会中开会？”
You were pissed about that?
“你对此感到愤怒？”
Totally.
“完全是。”
Yeah.
“是的。”
Because I wasn't involved.
“因为我没参与进去。”
Why were you angry about that?
“你为什么对此感到愤怒？”
Because here I am trying to build something with the school. Why didn't you just involve me? Why didn't you just tell me about it?
“因为我在这里努力与学校共同建设某些东西。为什么你们不让我参与？为什么不告诉我？”
It felt like it was a secret. I don't know if it was, if it wasn't. I'm invested in the school. And clearly, I've proven to you I'm invested in the school, and you couldn't tell us that you wanted to fundraise in a different way?
“感觉就像个秘密。我不知道它是否是，或者是否不是。我为这所学校投入了心血。显然，我已经向你证明了这一点，而你竟然不能告诉我们你想以不同的方式筹款？”
Rob and the new parents did tell the principal that they wanted to fundraise in a different way, but Imee felt like, what about the rest of us? She felt like the PTA was ignored. At that last meeting, Imee went quiet. She told me she just felt enraged and then embarrassed for feeling so enraged.
罗布和新家长确实告诉校长他们想以不同的方式筹款，但艾米觉得：其他人怎么办？她觉得PTA被忽视了。在最后一次会议上，艾米沉默了。她告诉我她只是感到愤怒，然后为自己感到如此愤怒而感到尴尬。
I guess I just threw a tantrum. [LAUGHS] And I just didn't want to be a part of it, which is not right. But I think, again, in the moment, I just felt like-- you know, I was hurt.
“我猜我只是发了脾气。[笑] 我只是不想参与其中，那是不对的。但我认为，再一次，在那一刻，我只是觉得——你知道，我受伤了。”
Didn't you throw-- was the tantrum the thing I saw? Because that did not seem like a tantrum.
“你没发脾气——那是我看到的吗？因为那看起来不像脾气。”
No, that was not a tantrum. I could have been a lot worse, and I was really, really trying to restrain myself. Yeah, I really was. That was really under control, really, really under control. It wasn't, but it was really, really under control.
“不，那不是脾气。我可能会更糟，但我真的、真的在极力克制自己。是的，我确实在克制。那真的是在控制之下，真的，真的在控制之下。虽然不是，但确实是在控制之下。”
I asked, was there another time?
我问：“还有其他时候吗？”
Tantrum? Yeah, at home with my husband. [LAUGHS] That's when I threw my tantrum.
“脾气？有，在家里对我丈夫。[笑] 那才是我发脾气的时候。”
So it was tense among the parents, but this is a school for children. Did it matter if the adults were not getting along or who controlled which pot of money? Yes, yes it did.
所以家长们之间很紧张，但这是一所学校，是为了孩子们。成年人是否相处融洽，或者谁控制了哪笔钱，真的重要吗？是的，非常重要。
That's coming up after the break from WBEZ Chicago when our program continues.
节目稍后继续，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Nice White Parents. Chana Joffe-Walt is telling the story of parents and their influence over the workings of one public school, a public school in Brooklyn called SIS, the School for International Studies.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《不错的白人家长》。查娜·乔夫-沃尔特正在讲述家长们以及他们对布鲁克林一所名为SIS（国际研究学校）公立学校运作的影响。
Chana picks up now where she left off. The school year moved forward. Rob's fundraising committee moved forward with the French embassy to plan the fundraiser. It was now being called a gala. The PTA moved forward with parent volunteers to plan a spring carnival. It was being called the spring carnival-- quiet resentments locked in place. Here's Chana.
查娜现在从上次中断的地方继续讲起。学年向前推进。罗布的筹款委员会继续与法国大使馆合作策划筹款活动，现在被称为“晚宴”（Gala）。PTA继续组织家长志愿者筹划春季嘉年华。它被称为“春季嘉年华”——沉默的怨恨固定在原地。有请查娜。
I was talking on the phone one night to Imee's co-president on the PTA, Susan Moesker. She told me she was worried the school was changing in ways that were damaging to the community. Susan is white herself, but she didn't come in with the new parents. When she started, her son was one of the only white kids in the school. Now Susan felt like they were all being written into a narrative that wasn't true, that SIS was a bad school before, and now that the new white families had arrived, it was being turned around.
有一天晚上，我在电话里与艾米的PTA联席主席苏珊·莫斯克交谈。她告诉我，她担心学校正以损害社区的方式发生变化。苏珊本人也是白人，但她不是和那批新家长一起来的。当她开始时，她的儿子是学校里仅有的几名白人孩子之一。现在，苏珊觉得他们都被写进了一个并非真相的叙事里：即SIS以前是一所糟糕的学校，而现在随着新的白人家庭到来，它正在被扭转局面。
It is noticeable. I think it is something that even my child has picked up on-- just, like, a very different feeling among some of the students and some of the parents. This real sense, again, that here they come to save our poor, struggling school that couldn't possibly make it on its own without their money and their vision. And we do not all feel that is necessarily the case.
“这是显而易见的。我认为即使是我的孩子也注意到了这一点——只是在一些学生和家长之间，感觉非常不同。这种真实的感觉是：他们来了，来拯救我们那所贫困、挣扎的学校，如果没有他们的钱和愿景，学校根本无法生存。我们并不都觉得事实一定如此。”
What do you feel?
“你有什么感觉？”
[CHUCKLES] Uh--
[轻笑] 呃——
This was a long conversation. The upshot, she's not happy with the way the new parents are behaving. It was true, a new narrative was taking hold at SIS. It's not like the kids were talking about it all the time, but it was in the air. And the kids were starting to pick up on who was valued and why.
这是一个漫长的谈话。最终的结论是：她对新家长的行为方式不满意。这是真的，一种新的叙事在SIS占据了上风。并不是孩子们一直在谈论它，但它弥漫在空气中。孩子们开始注意到谁受到重视以及原因。
In the cafeteria, I'd hear middle schoolers saying, the French kids could kill someone, and they'd get away with it. Upstairs in the high school, I'd hear kids complain, all the attention has shifted to the new middle schoolers. We're being pushed aside.
在自助餐厅，我会听到中学生说：“法语班的孩子就算杀了人，也能全身而退。”在楼上的高中部，我会听到孩子们抱怨：“所有的注意力都转移到了新的初中生身上。我们被推到了一边。”
And down in the library, I met three sixth grade boys, white boys new to SIS. They're sweaty from playing soccer and looking very small against their huge backpacks. These boys, even at 11 years old, they've absorbed the same messages that SIS wasn't so good before. It was a bad school.
在图书馆，我遇到了三名六年级男生，都是刚加入SIS的白人男孩。他们刚踢完足球，大汗淋漓，在巨大的书包对比下显得非常瘦小。这些男孩，即使在11岁时，也吸收了同样的信息，即SIS以前并不怎么好。这是一所糟糕的学校。
The kids wouldn't pay attention. And they had, like-- got to, like, zone out every little thing. And I bet they learned very little. And now this generation with us, I think we're doing a lot better. And I think that we're learning at a much faster pace.
“孩子们不注意听讲。他们不得不——得把每件小事都隔离出来。我敢打赌他们学不到什么东西。而现在这一代人，和我们在一起，我觉得我们做得好多了。而且我认为我们正在以更快的速度学习。”
He and his friends, they've turned the school around. That's what he's learning.
他和他的朋友们扭转了学校的局面。这就是他所学到的。
It's going to be one of the top choices already in the book. Like when you're applying to middle schools, you get a book sort of on statuses and stuff. And I think this school's actually really high up in the statuses.
“它已经在书中成为首选之一了。就像你申请中学时，你得到一本书，上面写着地位之类的东西。我认为这所学校的地位实际上真的很高。”
Nobody calls it the book on statuses. They call it a directory of schools with info like enrollment numbers for different schools, test scores, and special programs. But I love that he calls it the book on statuses, because this is what happened at SIS. The school had a bad reputation among white families, and then suddenly it was in demand. Its status had changed because of the white kids.
没人称之为“地位书”。他们称之为学校目录，提供 enrollment（入学人数）、考试成绩和特色项目等信息。但我喜欢他称之为“地位书”，因为这正是SIS发生的事情。这所学校在白人家庭中名声不好，然后突然间变得抢手。它的地位因为白人孩子的到来而改变了。
A powerful draw for white families into any school is other white families. Once you have a critical mass of white kids, you pass what one city calls a bliss point. This is a real thing researchers study, how many white kids are needed at a school to make other white families feel comfortable choosing it. That number, the bliss point, is 26%. That fall, white families were crowding the school tours at SIS, not because the test scores had improved-- the new scores hadn't even come out yet-- but because the other white families made them feel blissfully comfortable.
对白人家庭进入任何学校的一个强大吸引力就是其他白人家庭。一旦你有了足够数量的白人孩子，你就会越过一个城市所称的“极乐点”（bliss point）。这是一项研究人员研究的真实事物，即学校需要多少白人孩子才能让其他白人家庭感到足够舒适而选择它。那个数字，极乐点，是26%。那年秋天，白人家庭挤满了SIS的参观团，不是因为考试成绩提高了——新的成绩还没出来——而是因为其他白人家庭让他们感到舒适。
Of course, the thing that made the new white parents comfortable coming to SIS in the first place was the promise of a French program. They wanted French, and they got French. So now all the sixth, seventh, eighth, and ninth graders are learning French.
当然，最初让新白人家长感到舒适而选择SIS的原因是法语项目的承诺。他们想要法语，他们得到了法语。所以现在所有六年级、七年级、八年级和九年级的学生都在学习法语。
It wasn't a true dual-language program where kids learned in French for half a day or whatever. That first year, most of the French was happening in the after-school program. You sign up for regular after-school stuff like culinary, or soccer, or drama, and it would be conducted in French.
这不是真正的双语项目，即孩子们半天都在学习法语或其他课程。第一年，大部分法语是在课后项目进行的。你报名参加常规的课后活动，如烹饪、足球或戏剧，它们会用法语进行。
Hey! Hey! Hey! [CLAPPING]
“嘿！嘿！嘿！”[拍手]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语对话]
Hey, everybody, you have to listen. OK.
“嘿，各位，你们得听着。好的。”
We're in the auditorium. And it's sweet. The kids are on stage, rehearsing this play they wrote in French. And it looked like they're having fun, but I couldn't help feeling like there's something off balance about this. Most of the kids doing this drama program seem to be native French speakers, but not all. A sixth grader named Maya is standing to the side of the stage, script in hand, waiting for her line.
我们在礼堂里。这很可爱。孩子们在舞台上，排练他们用法语写的剧本。看起来他们玩得很开心，但我忍不住觉得这其中有些失衡。参加这个戏剧项目的大多数孩子似乎是法语母语者，但不是全部。一个叫玛雅（Maya）的六年级学生站在舞台边上，手拿剧本，等着她的台词。
For me, it's like a bit weird because I have no idea what they're saying. Yeah.
“对我来说，这有点奇怪，因为我根本不知道他们在说什么。是啊。”
Really? Even in the play that you've been practicing, you don't know what they're saying?
“真的吗？即使在你排练的剧本中，你也不知道他们在说什么？”
Yeah, I don't know what they're saying still.
“是啊，我还是不知道他们在说什么。”
You have translations on the script.
“剧本上有翻译。”
Yeah, but sometimes when the teacher talks in French to the class, I don't understand.
“是啊，但有时当老师对全班用法语说话时，我听不懂。”
And do you figure it out, or is it confusing?
“你会把它弄明白，还是会感到困惑？”
Confusing.
“困惑。”
Still, she's excited. She's grinning watching the other kids on stage. She's hanging out with her friend Constance. Maya gets up to deliver her lines.
尽管如此，她很兴奋。她咧着嘴看着台上的其他孩子。她和她的朋友康斯坦斯（Constance）待在一起。玛雅站起来说她的台词。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语对话]
Oh, you did a wrong line.
“哦，你台词错了。”
Yeah. Wait, what? That's confusing.
“是啊。等等，什么？那很困惑。”
You just say [FRENCH]. And then [FRENCH] would be after.
“你只是说[法语]。然后[法语]应该在后面。”
I thought you had that line.
“我还以为你有那句台词。”
Constance, a native French speaker, tells Maya, you said the wrong thing. Constance corrects her, pronounces it for her.
康斯坦斯，一位法语母语者，告诉玛雅：“你说错了。”康斯坦斯纠正了她，为她做了发音示范。
OK. [SPEAKING FRENCH]
“好的。[法语对话]”
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语对话]
But it's OK.
“但没关系。”
Yeah, because I can't say it that well.
“是啊，因为我说得没那么好。”
Maya says, I can't. And her friend says, I'll do it for you.
玛雅说：“我不会。”而她的朋友说：“我来替你做。”
OK, I'll just--
“好的，我只是——”
Yeah, you do it.
“是啊，你做吧。”
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语对话]
Learning another language is not new to Maya.
学习另一种语言对玛雅来说并不新鲜。
My dad speaks Arabic, and my mom's Turkish.
“我爸爸说阿拉伯语，我妈妈是土耳其人。”
And now you're learning French.
“而现在你正在学法语。”
Yes, so confusing, three languages at the same time.
“是啊，太困惑了，同时学三种语言。”
Yeah.
“是啊。”
When the new white parents asked for a dual-language French program at SIS, Principal Juman said yes. SIS was supposedly an international school, but she told me they didn't really have a lot of international programming. So it seemed like a good idea to her. But there was no schoolwide debate about it or consensus. The community didn't decide. What if they had?
当新白人家长要求在SIS开设法语双语项目时，朱曼校长答应了。SIS理应是一所国际学校，但她告诉我他们并没有太多国际项目。所以这看起来是个好主意。但并没有关于此的全校性辩论或共识。社区并没有决定。如果他们决定了呢？
More than a third of the families at SIS are Hispanic. What if the dual-language program was Spanish or Arabic? 10% of the students speak Arabic. If they had made a different choice, if SIS had a dual-language Arabic program, Maya would be teaching Constance how to read her lines. She'd be the one explaining the cultural references and teasing her friend about her terrible accent. She'd be the one translating the teacher's stage directions.
SIS超过三分之一的家庭是西班牙裔。如果双语项目是西班牙语或阿拉伯语呢？10%的学生说阿拉伯语。如果他们做了不同的选择，如果SIS有一个阿拉伯语双语项目，玛雅就会教康斯坦斯如何朗读台词。她会是那个解释文化参考资料、嘲笑朋友糟糕口音的人。她会是那个翻译老师舞台指示的人。
There was money for a French program, which meant that, at SIS, French had value. Arabic didn't. Spanish didn't. That's something Maya is learning at school along with her French script.
法语项目有资金，这意味着在SIS，法语有价值。阿拉伯语没有，西班牙语没有。那是玛雅和她的法语剧本一起在学校学到的东西。
From the very beginning, Imee and the others had insisted on three things from the new parents and the fundraising committee-- that the gala fundraiser they were planning with the French embassy would, number one, be open to everyone, number two, take place at the school, and number three, be free. Then four weeks before the gala, the PTA asked for an update. And a parent named Deb showed up, a mom to a new sixth grader, part of Rob's fundraising committee.
从一开始，艾米和其他人就对新家长和筹款委员会坚持三点：他们策划的与法国大使馆合作的晚宴筹款活动，第一，必须对所有人开放；第二，在学校举行；第三，免费。在晚宴前四周，PTA要求更新进展。一位叫黛布（Deb）的家长出现了，她是新六年级学生的妈妈，也是罗布筹款委员会的一员。
So I will start with the fact that I had a nice conversation with--
“那么我先从我和……进行了愉快的交谈开始。”
Fabrice?
“法布里斯（Fabrice）？”
--Fabrice. Is it Fabrice?
“——法布里斯。是法布里斯吗？”
Fabrice, yeah.
“法布里斯，是的。”
Deb volunteered early on to help organize the party. And she tells everyone, I met with our partner, Fabrice, at the French embassy. And the event can't be at the school. The embassy won't be able to draw their supporters to Brooklyn. It'll be at the Cultural Services building on the Upper East Side, Manhattan, 45 minutes away.
黛布很早就自愿帮忙筹备聚会。她告诉大家：“我和大使馆的合作伙伴法布里斯见了面。活动不能在学校举行。大使馆无法将他们的支持者吸引到布鲁克林。它将在曼哈顿上东区的文化服务大楼举行，那儿距离这里有45分钟车程。”
I apologize if I'm saying things you guys already know, but I didn't know some of this info, so it was good. But the event is really-- it's their event. It's not really our event.
“如果我说的是你们已经知道的事情，我表示歉意，但我不知道其中的一些信息，所以这很好。但活动确实是——那是他们的活动。那不是我们的活动。”
Oh.
“哦。”
It's their event.
“那是他们的活动。”
That's Susan with the "oh." Maurice leans forward, elbows on the table. Imee is not here. She knew the meeting would be almost entirely about fundraising, and she's sitting this one out. Maurice is now concentrating on Rob, who turns to Deb and says, in what sense is it their event? They make the rules, she says.
那是苏珊发出的“哦”。莫里斯身体前倾，手肘撑在桌子上。艾米不在。她知道会议几乎全是关于筹款，所以她没参加。莫里斯现在专注于罗布，罗布转向黛布说：“什么意义上是他们的活动？”她说：“他们制定规则。”
With our input, but there are certain things that are not flexible. The biggest thing is nobody will be allowed in at the door. You have to be on a list. You have to RSVP. You have to be on the list-- all names.
“我们在提供意见，但有某些东西是不灵活的。最重要的一点是，没有人会被允许在门口进入。你必须在名单上。你必须回复确认。你必须在名单上——所有名字。”
Security-- it's a government building, after all.
安检——毕竟这是一栋政府大楼。
He sends out the invitation to 22,000 people on his mailing list. So now making it a free event is a problem because now we're inviting 22,000 people for free to drink wine and eat food that may not have any interest in us. So we thought the best thing to do would be a suggested donation. Can't afford to go--
“他向他通讯录上的2.2万人发送了邀请。所以现在让它成为一个免费活动成了问题，因为现在我们邀请了2.2万人免费来喝红酒吃东西，他们可能对我们毫无兴趣。所以我们认为最好的做法是建议捐赠。如果负担不起……”
Can I give a variant on that?
“我能给出一个变体吗？”
Yeah.
“可以。”
That's Rob, asking to give a variant, which is, how about we have a separate invitation for our people that doesn't ask for any money? Rob seems to be picking up on the instant irritation in this room, and he's adding many variants to Deb's report.
那是罗布，请求给出变体，即：我们能否为我们的人提供一份不需要钱的单独邀请？罗布似乎察觉到了房间里瞬间的烦躁，他在黛布的报告中增加了很多变体。
It's either a modified version or just a clarity that everybody in this community--
“要么是修改版本，要么是明确所有人都在这个社区里……”
He won't. There'll be one invite. It will say the same-- that's what I suggested. I suggested $50 a head for outside.
“他不会那样做。只有一份邀请函。上面会说同样的——我建议了。我建议对外收费50美元一个人。”
Even if we simply put a cover note saying no charge, we want you to come join us, our community.
“即使我们简单地附上一张纸条说免费，我们希望你们来加入我们，我们的社区。”
Right. But on the invite, it will say suggested donation. Then if you want to-- however we want to forward it, we can say that. But they will only do one invite.
“对。但在邀请函上，它会写‘建议捐赠’。然后如果我们想——无论我们想如何转发它，我们可以那样说。但他们只会做一份邀请。”
Deb hasn't been able to make previous PTA meetings, so all Deb knows is she got an email from the fundraising committee at her kid's new school, which she assumed was part of the PTA. She's volunteering her time, a ton of her time to organize a huge event. She does not understand that the email list she's on is for a separate fundraising committee that just became even more unpopular with the official PTA leadership. I think I stopped moving, watching Deb. It's so tense. She's like a porcupine who's just wandered into a balloon store.
黛布没能参加之前的PTA会议，所以黛布所知道的只是她从孩子新学校的筹款委员会收到了一封邮件，她认为那是PTA的一部分。她自愿贡献她的时间，大量时间去组织一场大型活动。她不明白她所在的邮件列表是属于一个独立的筹款委员会，该委员会在正式的PTA领导层中变得更加不受欢迎。我想我停止了移动，盯着黛布。气氛太紧张了。她就像一只误入气球店的豪猪。
They're serving wine, water, and then French hors d'oeuvres. As far as the auction, we have a couple of cleanses. We have restaurants. We have a soccer camp. We have a vacation rental in California. We got a couple hair salons-- very few from the community here. And that's really what I wanted to talk about.
“他们提供红酒、水，还有法式开胃小菜。至于拍卖，我们有几个清洁礼券。我们有餐厅券。我们有足球训练营。我们在加州有度假出租屋。我们有几家美发沙龙——很少来自这里的社区。这真是我想要谈论的。”
From the parent community or the geographic community?
“来自家长社区还是地理社区？”
Parent community and geographic community.
“家长社区和地理社区。”
Deb says at her kid's elementary school, they got a lot more donated items from parents. She tells the room, you can ask at the restaurants you go to if they do gift certificates, the salon, your employers. You'd be surprised what people can offer. Just ask.
黛布说，在她孩子以前的学校，他们从家长那里收到了更多捐赠物品。她告诉房间里的人：“你可以向你常去的餐厅询问他们是否提供礼券、沙龙券、你的雇主。你会惊讶于人们能提供什么。去问问就行了。”
And that's what I do with my friends. Most of my friends, though, they're all in other schools. I'm just new here. I don't really know many people, so. The only people I've been able to reach out to are the 36 on Rob's email list.
“这就是我和朋友做的事。不过我大多数朋友都在其他学校。我刚到这里。我不怎么认识人，所以。我唯一能联系到的是罗布名单上的36个人。”
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
And a quarter of them gave, donated something already, like found something. So I'm telling you, that house in Sonoma County is gorgeous-- four bedroom, three bath-- beautiful.
“其中四分之一已经捐赠了一些东西，找到了某些东西。所以我告诉你们，索诺玛县的那栋房子美极了——四卧三卫——很漂亮。”
I think about a PTA meeting a few months before, where I watched Imee gently explain to one of the new parents why it might be hard for some families to throw in $5 for classroom supplies, that even being asked to donate can feel alienating. Some people in this room seem to be experiencing this whole thing as a routine update about public school volunteering. Others look like someone who's walked into the wrong room and is now looking around to the friends they came with for affirmation. We're in the wrong room, right? How do we get out?
我想到几个月前的PTA会议，当时我看着艾米耐心地向一位新家长解释为什么有些家庭拿出5美元买课堂用品可能会很困难，即便是被要求捐款也可能感到疏远。房间里有些人似乎把这一切体验为关于公立学校志愿服务的常规更新。另一些人看起来像是走进了一个错误的房间，现在正看向他们一起来的朋友寻求确认。“我们进错房间了，对吧？我们怎么出去？”
Usually I get more tickets to shows, games, things. Like, I've gotten Broadway tickets. But I haven't gotten anything in the ticket arena-- Knicks.
“我通常能拿到更多演出的票、比赛票。比如，我拿到过百老汇的票。但我还没拿到门票领域的——尼克斯队。”
I have a contact at the Nets. I'm willing to reach out to--
“我在篮网队有联系人。我愿意去联系……”
Yeah. They always go. Everybody wants to go to a game. There's always somebody. And they also make great Christmas gifts.
“是啊。他们总是去。每个人都想去看比赛。总是有人想要。它们也作为很棒的圣诞礼物。”
And that's the other thing where we're lacking, is actual items. We used to have a parent-- well, we still have the parent, but she's not at my school-- that worked at Tiffany. And we always had some beautiful Tiffany pieces or a Coach bag. Some products makes it look nice.
“而这正是我们缺乏的，是实际物品。我们过去有一个家长——嗯，我们仍然有那位家长，但她不在我学校——她在蒂芙尼工作。我们总是会有一些漂亮的蒂芙尼首饰或蔻驰包。有一些产品能让它看起来很好。”
I spent a small chunk of that meeting occupied by an admittedly sentimental thought. Just looking around, the room was kind of incredible-- people with homes in Sonoma and people who live in public housing sitting together at a long, wooden table in the library of a public school that they all share. That never happens. And I didn't want them to mess it up. But, of course, they are. This is not something we have a lot of practice in.
我花了那次会议的一小部分时间来思考一个不可否认的感伤想法。环顾四周，房间简直不可思议——有索诺玛有房产的人和住在公共住房的人，坐在一个公立学校图书馆的长木桌旁，他们共享这所学校。那从未发生过。我不想让他们搞砸了。但当然，他们正在这样做。这不是我们有很多实践经验的事情。
New York City has one of the most segregated school systems in the country. White parents here have very little practice sharing public schools. Maybe this is all to be expected. White parents will charge ahead, will sometimes be careless, secretive, or entitled. In response, parents of color will sometimes be cautious or distrustful, defensive. These are well-established patterns repeated over generations. It's easier for us to continue operating on separate tracks because it's what we already know how to do.
纽约市拥有全国最隔离的学校系统之一。这里的白人家长几乎没有共享公立学校的实践经验。也许这一切都在预料之中。白人家长会冲在前面，有时会粗心大意、秘密行事或理所当然。作为回应，有色人种家长有时会谨慎、不信任或防御。这些是几代人重复的成熟模式。我们更容易在独立的轨道上继续运作，因为那是我们已经知道如何去做的事情。
The guy from the French embassy apparently has a mailing list of 22,000 people in the New York area. 300 people RSVP to the gala for SIS. I couldn't believe it. And I couldn't believe that one of them was Imee.
法国大使馆的那个人显然在纽约地区拥有一个2.2万人的邮件列表。300人确认参加SIS的晚宴。我简直不敢相信。我更不敢相信其中之一是艾米。
Hello.
“你好。”
Good evening.
“晚上好。”
You guys look lovely.
“你们看起来很可爱。”
Hi. How are you?
“嘿。你好吗？”
Imee, Maurice, and Susan carpooled together to the Upper East Side. It's winter. Central Park is across the street. It's cold. Imee told me she decided she needed to be a grown-up and come. They got stuck in traffic, so they're rushing up the sidewalk.
艾米、莫里斯和苏珊一起拼车到了曼哈顿上东区。是冬天。中央公园在马路对面。天很冷。艾米告诉我她决定要表现得像个成年人并过来。他们堵车了，所以他们正匆忙走上人行道。
We're not that late, are we, Susan?
“我们没那么晚吧，苏珊？”
It's not serious.
“不严重。”
No, we're not that late.
“不，我们没那么晚。”
The Cultural Services building is ivy covered with columns. The doors are wrought iron. The entryway is marble.
文化服务大楼被常春藤覆盖，配有圆柱。大门是锻铁的。入口是大理石的。
Hey. How are you?
“嘿。你好吗？”
Hi. You guys all came in together? All right. So put us to work.
“嘿。你们一起进来的吗？好的。给我们安排工作吧。”
A huge marble staircase winds up the side of the room. Later, I look up the architectural style-- Italian renaissance, palazzo style. It's a palace. There are people milling, sampling 17 different cheeses. I don't recognize anyone else from the school. Who are these people who have chosen to come out on a weekday evening for a fundraising event for a not prominent or well known at all public school in Brooklyn?
巨大的大理石楼梯盘旋在房间一侧。后来，我查了一下建筑风格——意大利文艺复兴，宫殿式。这是一座宫殿。人们在走动，品尝17种不同的奶酪。我不认识学校里的其他人。这些人是谁，选择在一个工作日的晚上出来参加一个对布鲁克林一所完全不出名、也完全不为人知的公立学校的筹款活动？
I'm not involved with the school, but my wife is involved with the--
“我不参与学校事务，但我妻子参与了……”
I started asking people how they heard about the event.
我开始问人们他们是怎么听到这个活动的。
And what brought you here tonight?
“是什么让你今晚来到这里？”
Actually, an invitation by my wonderful French professor.
“实际上，是我出色的法语教授邀请我的。”
A lady named Barbara tells me she's never heard of SIS, like most people here, but she loves French, and she loves Paris, and it sounded like a fun night with other people who do too. She goes to France every year.
一位叫芭芭拉（Barbara）的女士告诉我她从没听说过SIS，像这里的大多数人一样，但她热爱法语，热爱巴黎，听起来和有同样爱好的人一起度过一个有趣的夜晚很棒。她每年都去法国。
October is my saison préférée. Actually, I found this October too warm, but I like it when it's a nice fall, crisp, and you wear your scarf, your foulard.
“十月是我最喜欢的季节。事实上，我觉得这个十月太暖和了，但我喜欢秋天凉爽的时候，你戴着围巾、丝巾。”
I enjoy a person who likes to talk, where you can just get on their ride and sit back. Barbara is definitely that kind of person.
我喜欢这种健谈的人，你可以踏上他们的旅程坐下来享受。芭芭拉绝对是那种人。
And my apartment in Paris is sort of-- I'm confused sometimes. I say, am I in Gramercy Park, or am I in Saint-Germain-des-Prés? It's got a similar ambiance, being a neighborhood. It's great. Have you been?
“而我在巴黎的公寓……有时我会感到困惑。我说，我是在格拉梅西公园，还是在圣日耳曼德佩区？它有一种相似的氛围，作为一个社区。这太棒了。你去过吗？”
No, I've never been.
“没有，我从没去过。”
Oh my god, she hasn't been to Paris.
“哦，天哪，她没去过巴黎。”
Barbara's looking around for her French teacher to tell her the news. Barbara's teacher, it turns out, heard about this evening the same way most people here did. She was invited by this man, Fabrice.
芭芭拉四处寻找她的法语老师来告诉这个消息。结果，芭芭拉的老师听到这个晚会的方式和这里的大多数人一样。她是被这个人，法布里斯邀请的。
For the School for International Studies, we are hoping we will raise $100,000 each year for the next seven years.
“对于国际研究学校，我们希望在未来七年内每年筹集10万美元。”
Fabrice Jaumont works for the Cultural Services arm of the French embassy. He tells me he's fundraising for dual-language programs in public schools because his mission is to promote French language and culture. He called it soft power, which I was kind of surprised he said out loud, since I associate that with something we do in developing countries, not something you're allowed to do in American public schools. After Fabrice and I talked, I walked into the main room and immediately saw Maurice. Maurice was so skeptical of this whole embassy thing, but there he is at a table selling raffle tickets next to Imee, cheerfully raising money for a program neither of them ever wanted at their school.
法布里斯·若蒙（Fabrice Jaumont）为法国大使馆的文化服务部门工作。他告诉我他正在为公立学校的双语项目筹款，因为他的使命是推广法语语言和文化。他称之为“软实力”，当他大声说出来时我感到很惊讶，因为我把这与我们在发展中国家做的事情联系起来，而不是你在美国公立学校里被允许做的事情。法布里斯和我谈话后，我走进主房间，立刻看到了莫里斯。莫里斯对这个大使馆的事情非常怀疑，但此时他却坐在拉票桌旁，在艾米旁边，开心地为他们学校两人都不想要的课程筹款。
We are raffling off two airline tickets to France. One blue ticket's going to win. It could be yours.
“我们正在抽奖赢取两张去法国的机票。一张蓝色票会中奖。它可能是你的。”
Maurice, amiable as ever, is trying, and mostly failing, to convert ticket sales into social connections. He asks everyone, so if you win, when are you thinking of going? Oh, you're going anyway for Easter? Oh, nice.
莫里斯依然和蔼可亲，试图把门票销售转化为社交联系，尽管大多没成功。他问每个人：“那么如果你中奖了，你打算什么时候去？哦，你复活节反正要回去？哦，不错。”
How's the weather there in Easter?
“那里复活节天气怎么样？”
In France? Yes, I am from France.
“在法国吗？是的，我来自法国。”
How's the weather there in Easter?
“那里复活节天气怎么样？”
Good. Fantastic. Before we do it, I have a question. Can I, from here, from these tickets, buy something to go from Paris to Marseille when I'm leaving?
“好。太棒了。在我们做这件事之前，我有个问题。我能从这里，从这些票里，买一些东西让我离开时从巴黎去马赛吗？”
I don't know.
“我不知道。”
Barbara from Gramercy Park, the woman who loves fall in Paris, wanders across the marble floor toward the raffle table, the side where Imee is sitting. And I thought, oh, no.
格拉梅西公园的芭芭拉，那个热爱巴黎秋天的女人，在大理石地板上晃向抽奖桌，艾米坐着的那一侧。我想：“哦，不。”
It's a pleasure to meet you.
“见到你很高兴。”
Hi. How are you?
“嘿。你好吗？”
Good, thank you.
“好，谢谢。”
You're one of the parents of a bilingual student?
“你是双语学生的家长之一吗？”
She's not bilingual, but she does go to the school. [LAUGHS]
“她不是双语的，但她确实去那所学校。[笑]”
She will be bilingual eventually.
“她最终会成为双语的。”
Yes, eventually.
“是的，最终。”
What a wonderful thing. Are you pleased with the program?
“多么美妙的事情。你对这个项目满意吗？”
Yes. I love the school.
“是的。我爱这所学校。”
It's so important to learn another language. It opens the world for you. And what is your name?
“学习另一种语言太重要了。它为你打开了世界。你叫什么名字？”
Chana.
“查娜。”
Chana. I was just telling Chana, when I go to Paris, which I do every year--
“查娜。我刚才告诉查娜，当我每年去巴黎时……”
Cool.
“太酷了。”
It is cool. And it's cooler because I can speak the language. And you have entrée into the society-- not totally. One will never have total entrée, but you can interact with your neighbors. You can interact in a restaurant. You can interact at the dry cleaner, at the supermarket. And they so appreciate an American who can speak French.
“这很酷。而且因为它酷，我能说这种语言。你拥有进入社会的入场券——不是完全的。一个人永远不会有完全的入场券，但你可以与你的邻居互动。你可以在餐厅互动。你可以在干洗店、超市互动。他们非常欣赏会说法语的美国人。”
Yeah.
“是啊。”
Yes, yes. And the language is beautiful.
“是的，是的。这种语言很美。”
Imee starts looking around. Maurice moves closer and leans in to hear why his wife is doing that nervous laugh as Barbara explains to Imee, a Puerto Rican woman, that being bilingual makes a person more sophisticated. Imee is exceedingly polite.
艾米开始四处张望。莫里斯走近靠过来听他的妻子为什么发出那种紧张的笑声，因为芭芭拉正在向艾米，一位波多黎各女士，解释说双语让一个人更成熟。艾米非常有礼貌。
Paris is a lodestar. And if you really want to enjoy it, you've got to speak the language. It was a pleasure. Thank you.
“巴黎是一颗北极星。如果你真的想享受它，你必须说这种语言。不胜荣幸。谢谢。”
That entire conversation, Imee never mentioned to Barbara that she does speak another language, Spanish. Later, I ask her why. She shrugs it off.
在整个谈话中，艾米从未向芭芭拉提到她确实会说另一种语言，西班牙语。后来，我问她为什么。她耸耸肩。
I was like, no, I'll just let her talk. It's OK. It was all right, so.
“我当时想，不，我还是让她说吧。没关系。这没什么，所以。”
Do you remember when you were telling me about the silent tantrum that you're having?
“你还记得你告诉我那个沉默的脾气吗？”
Yeah.
“是的。”
How would I know if that was happening?
“如果那发生了我怎么知道？”
You wouldn't. Only my husband would-- [LAUGHS] --if I'm throwing a silent tantrum.
“你不会知道。只有我丈夫会——[笑] ——如果我正在发沉默的脾气。”
Oh, yeah.
“哦，是啊。”
[LAUGHS] He would know if I'm throwing a silent tantrum.
[笑] “如果我正在发沉默的脾气，他会知道的。”
So is that happening right now?
“那么现在发生了吗？”
No, not right now.
“不，现在没有。”
Imee turns her back to her husband, facing me. And behind her Maurice is looking right at me, nodding vigorously, yes.
艾米背对着她的丈夫，面对着我。而在她身后，莫里斯正看着我，用力地点头，是的。
So here we were in our fancy clothes on the Upper East Side of Manhattan, raising money for a French program at an utterly normal Brooklyn public school. That was already weird. But the toasts-- the toasts were when the cognitive dissonance of the evening really kicked in for me. Fabrice steps up onto the marble staircase and clinks his glass, announces it's time to celebrate what we've created and raise some money.
所以我们穿着华丽的衣服在曼哈顿上东区，为布鲁克林一所完全正常的公立学校的法语项目筹款。那已经很奇怪了。但祝酒词——当晚的认知失调真的让我想起的时候。法布里斯走上大理石楼梯，碰了碰杯子，宣布是时候庆祝我们所创造的东西并筹集一些资金了。
It takes a village. It takes a dedicated principal. She's here with us. It takes-- yes, yes, yes.
“养育一个孩子需要一个村庄。它需要一位敬业的校长。她和我们在一起。它需要——是的，是的，是的。”
Fabrice hands the mic to Principal Juman.
法布里斯把麦克风交给了朱曼校长。
Hi.
“嘿。”
It's so nice to see all of you. And I think the number one thing is I think all of us standing here believe in public education and believe that all--
“很高兴见到你们所有人。我认为最重要的一件事是，我相信我们所有站在这里的人都相信公共教育，并且相信所有……”
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Yes.
“是的。”
One by one, people are talking about equality, and diversity, and community, and the meaning of public education here at the Cultural Services palatial palace full of white people.
人们一个个地谈论着平等、多元化、社区，以及公共教育的意义，就在这里，在充满白人的文化服务宫殿里。
So I went on the sixth grade trip, 11-year-olds going overnight trip up into the Catskills. I would not recommend doing that.
“所以我参加了六年级的旅行，11岁的孩子去卡茨基尔山隔夜旅行。我不建议这样做。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Rob gives a toast about that time he went on the overnight trip. It starts off OK, but then veers into strange and sort of cringey territory. He's on a ropes course 40 feet up, looking down.
罗布祝酒谈论了他那次隔夜旅行。它开始还可以，但随后转向了奇怪和某种令人尴尬的领域。他在离地40英尺高的绳索课程上，向下俯视。
Below me was that diverse group of kids. They were diverse kids belaying me, making sure that when I jump, they would actually cushion my fall. That day, each of those kids was going to climb up that pole and was going to have the same opportunity and the same challenge. And it made me think that that's what this school is about. It's about the opportunity to do the International Baccalaureate, the challenge of it-- so the opportunity to explore French and the challenge of it for all kids.
“在我下方是那群多元化的孩子们。他们是多元化的孩子在保护我，确保当我跳下时，他们实际上会缓冲我的坠落。那天，每个孩子都要爬上那个杆子，并拥有同样的机会和同样的挑战。这让我想到，这就是这所学校的意义。它是关于做国际文凭课程的机会，它的挑战——所以是有机会探索法语，以及对所有孩子来说的挑战。”
I agree with Rob. It's great to give kids equal access to opportunity. But what they're being given access to are the opportunities that Rob and the other white parents care about.
我同意罗布的观点。给孩子们平等的进入机会是很好的。但他们被给予进入的机会是罗布和其他白人家长关心的机会。
Downstairs, I find Susan, Imee's PTA co-president on a bench by herself. She's near the band, drinking wine, looking a little dumbstruck. I ask if she's OK. This is something else, she says. And then she adds, it's just hard to explain how this is a public school fundraiser.
楼下，我发现苏珊，艾米的PTA联席主席，独自坐在长椅上。她在乐队附近，喝着红酒，看起来有点惊呆了。我问她还好吗。她说，这是别的东西。然后她补充道：“很难解释这怎么能成为公立学校的筹款活动。”
When the founder of American public education, Horace Mann, laid out his vision for public schools back in the day, he rode his horse around Massachusetts, podium to podium. And his pitch was common schools would make democracy possible. They would bind us to one another, indoctrinate us, give us the skills and tools we need for democratic living. Public schools, he believed, would be the great equalizer. Rich and poor would come together and develop what he called "fellow feeling," and in doing so, quote, "obliterate factitious distinctions in society."
当美国公共教育的创始人贺拉斯·曼（Horace Mann）在过去提出他对公立学校的愿景时，他骑着马绕过马萨诸塞州，从一个讲台到另一个讲台。他的推销是普通学校会使民主成为可能。它们会把我们团结在一起，教导我们，赋予我们民主生活所需的技能和工具。他相信，公立学校将成为伟大的平等器。富人和穷人将聚在一起，发展他所谓的“同胞之情”，从而引用一句，“磨灭社会中的虚构区别”。
For that to happen, you need everyone in the same school together. At SIS, they've gotten that far. Everyone was in the same school together, but there was no equalizing. We can be in the same school together and not be equal, just like we can be in the same country together. It's not enough.
为了实现这一点，你需要每个人都在同一所学校里。在SIS，他们已经走到了那一步。每个人都在同一所学校里，但没有平等。我们可以在同一所学校里而不平等，就像我们在同一个国家里一样。这还不够。
After the gala, money poured into SIS, and more white families enrolled their kids at the school. But in the years after that, there was a backlash, and SIS changed in ways that made Rob question himself. He wondered if he'd made mistakes. He told me he thought they all wanted the same thing for the kids. He just didn't know.
晚宴后，资金涌入SIS，更多白人家庭为孩子报名入学。但在那之后的几年里，出现了反弹，SIS以让罗布质疑自己的方式发生了变化。他想知道他们是否犯了错。他告诉我他以为他们都想要孩子想要的东西。他只是不知道。
Not knowing-- that happens a lot with white parents. Most of us, we don't understand the buildings we walk into. We don't know what came before.
不知道——这在白人家长身上发生得很多。我们大多数人，我们不了解我们走进的建筑。我们不知道之前发生了什么。
I looked into the history of this school and I learned that this wasn't the first time white parents showed up here. White parents have been involved all along, all the way back to the very beginning of this school half a century ago, doing the same kinds of things I'd just seen. It happens again and again-- white parents wielding their power without even noticing, like a guy wandering through a crowded store with a huge backpack, knocking things over every time he turns.
我研究了这所学校的历史，了解到这并不是白人家长第一次出现在这里。白人家长从头到尾一直都在参与，一直到半个世纪前这所学校开始的时候，做着我刚才看到的同样的事情。它一次又一次地发生——白人家长动用他们的权力却甚至没有注意到，就像一个背着巨大背包在拥挤商店里走动的家伙，每次转身都会把东西撞倒。
Horace Mann believed public schools would make us equal, but it doesn't work. I'm not sure how to fix that, but I want to lay out the story, the whole story of this one American public school. Because what I am sure of is that, in order to address inequality in our public schools, we are going to need a shared sense of reality. At the very least, it's a place to start.
贺拉斯·曼相信公立学校会使我们平等，但它不起作用。我不确定如何修复它，但我想要摆出这个故事，这所美国公立学校的整个故事。因为我所确定的是，为了解决我们公立学校的不平等问题，我们将需要一种共同的现实感。至少，这是一个开始的地方。
Chana Joffe-Walt. That mission is what Chana takes up in the other episodes in her series, Nice White Parents. It's produced by our colleagues who we made the Serial Podcast with and distributed by The New York Times. Episodes one and two are out right now. And can I say, episode two is a completely different kind of story about a different and very idealistic group of white parents right when the school was founded. You can find Nice White Parents wherever you get your podcasts.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。那个使命是查娜在她的系列节目《不错的白人家长》的其他剧集中承担的。它由我们的制作同事制作，我们和他们一起制作了《序列》（Serial）播客，并由《纽约时报》发行。第一集和第二集现在已经发布。我能说，第二集是一个完全不同类型的故事，关于学校刚成立时的一群不同且非常理想主义的白人家长。你可以在你获得播客的任何地方找到《不错的白人家长》。
Our episode today was produced by Julie Snyder, with editing by Sarah Koenig, Neil Drumming, and me. Editorial consulting from Rachel Lissy and Eve Ewing. Fact checking by Ben Phelan. Stowe Nelson makes the show. Special thanks today to Nikole Hannah-Jones, Scott Sargrad, Jackie Carrier, and Lenny Garcia. Lilly Sullivan figured out how to fit their show into an episode of our show, with production help from Matt Tierney and Catherine Raimondo.
我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）制作，萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）和我负责编辑。编辑咨询来自瑞秋·利西（Rachel Lissy）和伊芙·尤因（Eve Ewing）。事实核查由本·费伦（Ben Phelan）负责。斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）制作节目。特别感谢今天的妮可·汉娜-琼斯（Nikole Hannah-Jones）、斯科特·萨格拉德（Scott Sargrad）、杰基·卡里尔（Jackie Carrier）和莱尼·加西亚（Lenny Garcia）。莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）想出了如何将他们的节目塞进我们节目的一集中，制作帮助来自马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和凯瑟琳·雷蒙多（Catherine Raimondo）。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, on his vacation he spotted some dolphins, but, dude, don't get him started on dolphins. He is not into them.
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交换）分发到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，在他的假期里他发现了一些海豚，但是，伙计，别让他谈论海豚。他不喜欢它们。
For me, it's a bit weird, because I have no idea what they're saying. Yeah.
“对我来说，这有点奇怪，因为我根本不知道他们在说什么。是啊。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。